award-winning director Ava Duvernay is
turning her powerful productions into a
resource for classrooms an independent
study today Ava Duvernay is launching a
new initiative called array 101 a raise
the name of her company it will offer
free learning guides for students and
really anyone interested in social
justice she says to accompany TV and
film productions the first one is for
her miniseries when they see us released
almost one year ago this week it
documents the wrongful conviction of the
exonerated five only on CBS this morning
Dube Renee told us her goal is to
inspire a deeper conversation you start
to think you did a good job
and then one night you look away
director Ava Duvernay is a visionary
behind the critically acclaimed series
when they see us a four-part drama about
the five black boys wrongfully convicted
of a Central Park rape in 1989 she says
the emotional response led her team to
develop a new project so many people
came up to me and I cried I couldn't
finish it you know they felt very deeply
about it but I think what I fail to do
and what many of us in Hollywood feel
fail to do is connect the dots between
the thing you make and the the people
who are watching particularly young
people to bridge that intersection
between film and social justice do
Renee's production company array
partnered with participant media to
create what she calls a learning
companion for when they see us this -
she hopes these resources will empower
youth and inspire action people sign a
petition
everyone go to this protest everyone may
not be interested in taking action in
that way there's a whole array no pun
intended of options that we you know
suggest and really invite people to go
further and now ava we have another
story from Central Park
yes where a white woman is falsely
accusing a black man please call the
cops where do we begin to process Ava
when calls for help and I'm using help
and finger quotes in this particular
case we're really being used to weapons
against people of color we have to look
to history we're not the first to be in
this situation and I think the the idea
that we are helpless is this an idea
that I don't accept I think we can
continue to be learning how to combat
these things you know in this social
media age we react to it we're upset
about it for a day we tweet me post and
then we kind of move on and that
organizing principle that deeply
ingrained mission to change is what I
hope we can get to the viral video in
question shows a white woman in a
racially charged confrontation with a
black man in Central Park
he was bird-watching at the time when
she called police and made a false
accusation against
him specifically mentioning his race the
minute I saw it I knew it was gonna
happen before it even happened what do
you mean he says I might say an
african-american man is doing this you
as a student of history have context for
exactly what's going to happen next
no when the police come they will
historically and there's you know
overwhelming precedent that they will
believe her on sight and him his
background will be interrogated and
investigated this case he was a Harvard
graduate who's president of the
bird-watching Club you know he did it
and a prominent figure but he shouldn't
have to be that for him to have the
benefit of the doubt so what action can
white people who see themselves as
allies what can they do you know I
really feel strongly that that's not a
question that people who are not white
should answer you know we take on the
the emotional labor of racism and it is
not our job to explain to white folk how
to fix their broken selves in this
context right because there's a
brokenness there that says that I am
better that I can I will be believed
right that's what this woman grew up
with the privilege of being believed the
privilege of the presumption of
innocence
there are many educated Caucasian folk
who are talking to each other about it
they need to continue to do that so that
we can save our energy for survival and
thriving I did have a conversation with
will who out on this black mass you know
we're all supposed to wear masks yeah he
said well you shouldn't walk around with
the black mask where is your orange
bandana he goes why should it matter the
color the bandana that I'm wearing I
think it does matter I said my brother
Nicholas the other day he was jogging
and you're gonna be jogging in his
neighborhood he had a black mask in a
black hoodie and I'm like what are you
doing yeah and you know where we live
you know what that means you know the
New York Times had a very powerful front
page the other day where they listed up
names what is the impact that
coronavirus has had on the film industry
and maybe even on you personally yes
well you know I've lost crew member on
the project that I was just working on
no one was there when he passed away
and so the grappling with me not being
there I think is
with the plugs that I have lost because
so many of us are such a be their kind
of person you know you you are one of
those be their kind of people look in
the mirror hello mirror be able to do
that you feel son
so unmoored so I am anchored yeah that
your grief just sits right on top and
it's nowhere for it to go what's your
game plan moving forward for your
business Ava yeah you're not some black
woman own the business I say it's not a
mom-and-pop it's just a mom we're
working hard programming virtually
learning new ways to program I know
we're all trying to figure out ways to
adapt you're doing something different
or when they see us coming up yes you
know we're gonna go ahead and watch the
first episode of when they see us
together on the one-year anniversary
which is this Sunday May 31st I can't
think of a better way to watch it than
with you thanks Ava thank you thanks
girl I'll be watching with you Ava
Duvernay listen needless to say Anthony
Ava's very very ready and interested and
excited to get back to work what is she
waiting for she's waiting for the okay
from the governor and the mayor of Los
Angeles and once they give the okay to
go back to work she said I'm gonna wait
two more weeks after that to make sure
that it's really okay she has a lot of
project projects that she's working on
and clearly has a lot to say yeah I
loved when they see us Gail was such a
powerful show and I love this idea of
hers that as she put it connecting the
dots between the program and viewers
responses to it because a lot of people
at time people don't know what to do and
how to sort of to follow whatever their
gut gut reaction is to something that's
a that's that's an important thing to do
I think so yeah I think you're right
Anthony anything that jumped out to me
is her invitation to people to go
further to look deeper you know every
day on this program were engaged in the
day's events we're on deadline there's a
reason they call journalism the first
draft of history in her position she can
delve more deeply over longer term
periods and I think any opportunity any
invitation at this moment for deeper
reflection is a welcome one Gail
especially in the middle of the George
Floyd case a lot of people don't know
what to say or what to do or how to
react you know my favorite daughter said
a white colleague said is it okay to ask
my black friends how they're doing Kirby
said well it should be deeper than that
you should understand they're not doing
okay there was a bigger conversation to
be had here and there was a lots lots
more to follow